parlor ceo fired by the board
uh parlor has terminated ceo john matsey
according to uh meme
mart's uh memo mart sent to staffers
that has been obtained by fox news on
january 29 2021 the parlor board
controlled by rebecca mercer
decided to immediately terminate my
position as ceo of parliament i did not
participate in this decision
i understand that those who now control
the company have some
communication to employees and other
third parties that have unfortunately
created
confusion improvement prompted me to
make this public statement matsy wrote
that over the past few months he has
been met constant resistance to his
original
vision for the social media platform
following amazon web services decision
to shut parlor down for failure to
moderate agree
egregious content related to the january
six capital rights
thoughts yeah you know i'm going to
bring up a couple points here and then
really i want to get your take on this
because you're a ceo of a company a
founder of a company
i want to get your opinion on this you
know how old this guy is
the founder of parlor late 30s he's 27
28 years old
that's pretty impressive very okay 28
years old you're the ceo of parlor how
much you think this guy's worth
well at the peak or at the low
right now i don't know i checked his net
worth oh i don't think it's an accurate
net worth you read really
there's no way the net worth is accurate
his net worth collapsed probably 70 80
in the last 90 days so what has gone
down in the last night
what what did it say's net worth is 10
million bucks
okay no he's he's probably worth you
know
a number like that because the company
went all the way up to you know
750 750 million dollar company is it a
public traded company no no no i
don't know if it's actually all i'm
saying is as far as the way they were
valuing their company was around being
half a billion to a billion auto
companies
so from that to the drop off it's a
completely different story but what do
you think about them
so firing him i haven't listened you're
the ceo of a company you're a founder of
a company right i mean all i've ever
been is a
vp of sales at a company i've never
founded a company what does that entail
when you
found a company you're the ceo i assume
that you have a major hand in
selecting the board members yeah and
then they say hey buddy pat
hit the road what does that feel like oh
so
that means he doesn't have control of
the board that means
they own more shares of the company
potentially than he does so it's not
like he
is the founder the ceo that means he
raised
money uh to the point where a matter of
fact let me look at crunch base can you
look at mario pull up crunch base and
type in parlor
go to crunch base crunch base and then
type in parlor and parlors with an
e you think it's with an o but it's with
an e parlor
uh let's see how much money they've
raised parlor do you see it
okay type in parlor he just told you it
was with an e uh
mario did he do oh yeah he went oh okay
there you go kai was texting me okay so
go to click on parlor right there
i'd go up a little bit go up the other
way yeah yeah
founder 2018 angel okay keep going up
up up what so they haven't raised money
wait that okay number of investors two
highlights click on that
to the right right there uh rebecca
mercer
angel angel okay click on robert mercer
see how much he gave
are they disclosing it or no go up go up
robert mercer it says undisclosed amount
right okay undisclosed
then go to the next one go back and see
if we can find out if rebecca's number's
public interesting why would you make it
undisclosed
uh and this is also undisclosed they're
not saying it
same thing okay okay walk us what you
just did here okay so
okay so go go to another company go to
robinhood okay type and rob enough for
us to look at robin that's in the news
right now yeah robin hood so you go to
crunchbase.crunchbase.com what is
crunchbase
crunchbase tells you the the raising of
money the organization
details about like right there look if i
want to find out robin on how much money
they've raised
click on total funding amount right
there and then it tells you every time
they raise money so go down the first
time they raise money
all the way down to the first round they
raise to show okay so you have to have
the
free trial okay they raised 323 million
dollars a year and a half ago july 22nd
series e so e means
d c b a four rounds prior to ironically
enough two days ago three days ago they
they had their 2.4 billion dollars 2.4
billion
four billion in the middle so then if
you want to find out who it was
click on the number six click on uh
convertible node robinhood right there
let's see who was the people that were
involved
it's big names it's not small names
sequoia capital ribbit
new enterprise associates index venture
i mean they got
and recent horowitz i mean they got the
main guys that are putting money with
them
six investors came in put 2.4 billion
dollars so
partner middle of all that but listen
all of this stuff that people are saying
with robin hood
yeah look you can say all you want about
robin hood you can say anything you want
about robin take shots at them all you
want last thursday they had 175 000
new people that downloaded their app and
last thursday they had more people using
robinhood
than all the other brokerage accounts
combined let me put this again
last thursday after all this heat after
all this being trashed by
aoc musk everybody that trashed them
right
last thursday they had more people on
their app than anybody else all their
competition combined
right let's name the competition who
they're competing e-trade short trade
scottish trades
vanguard all of them so robin hood is
bigger than all these guys now not now i
didn't say bigger
traffic more people there remember it's
a free platform so
the market is not the market of higher
echelon you know it's more
five hundred dollars i'm going to buy
one stock i'm going to buy 10 cents
they're not quantity not quality
quantity and enough maybe some quality
they're starting to get quality
they're not going to just stay quantity
for too long you start off with quantity
robin hood is no joke at this point
robinhood is a 25 to 30 billion auto
companies are these big guys these
schwabs these e-trades these
scottrade these vanguards yeah
fidelities they got to be a little bit
nervous with this new guy
let's let's stay on parlor and go to
that here in a minute so i'm parlor
let's talk about partners i don't
know how much those guys bought from the
company
i don't know when somebody comes in and
they give you money
the next step after agreeing to give
money guess what's the next thing that's
talked about control
controls what controls i have so what is
controls
your salary your bonus uh how much money
you can spend
without without our approval if you want
to make spend a hundred thousand dollars
you don't need to approve if you're
spending a penny above a hundred
thousand dollars you need to get to
approval where you it can be a quarter
million a half a million and that can go
up
as the company is growing and you're
doing a better job the controls could be
what other things you can do outside the
controls could be a lot of different
things when you're raising money right
with the company
i don't know the controls of this guy i
have no idea i don't know how he set
himself
up if he's 27 28 he could be smart he
could be brilliant but
he's not that experienced to know what
controls matter and what controls don't
matter when he
you hear the saying when a man with
money meets a man with experience
the man with experience leaves with the
money
right the man with the money leaves with
the experience he just left with the
experience
wow okay profound that's literally
exactly exactly what just happened he
just left with experience so now
they're firing him what the hell does
that mean you're firing him
does this mean you have somebody in mind
that you're going to recruit
that's going to be able to get the web
services up and parlor's going to be
back up
so for some of the people that are part
of like
pro parlor community this could be a
good thing because if the board is
firing him
maybe they think if they bring somebody
from a google maybe they think if they
bring somebody from another company to
make the company be more independent
right in the middle
maybe they bring a former executive from
amazon to bring
maybe they think that connection is
going to get amazon to say fine we'll go
because the person that's now running
the company
is a former executive of amazon or
whatever now we feel a little bit more
comfortable i don't know
but if you do make a public firing of a
ceo
you do not look good if you don't have a
plan afterwards
i don't that makes sense or not of
course if you just fired me you better
have a plan so if within the next week
parlor's board doesn't have a new guy
gal leader that's going to be running it
that starts showing progress what was
your point about firing the guy
what statement did you want to make like
what was the motive
parlor's down nobody's downloading the
app they don't have
aws all the other web services don't
want to give them the business they keep
saying oh we're going to come out with a
new website oh something's going on
something
if you don't have a replacement you're
going to look like a fool yourself so
the board's about to look like a fool if
they don't come out with a replacement
this is not just him looking bad
the board's also going to look bad if
they don't bring somebody that's going
to make the company go back
to being let me ask you a question on
that do you think that companies are
being put in a position to maybe
a pressure position to make these type
of decisions to make the masses
maybe feel better about their company
how do you think they're processing
decisions like this because a lot of it
has been happening the last few weeks
on decisions being made that are made by
others so so that's a great question so
this leads to robin hood right your
tomah
hood so what does the name robin hood
mean
what does the name robin hood mean from
the rich gift to the reporters
steal from the government no remember
remember robin hood cartoon was
never steal from the rich it was steal
from the tax dealer
which is the government people get this
confused they think it's stealing from
the rich
the rich was the government right that's
what it meant so it's not steel from the
rich the rich creates
jobs the government who forces
tax on you is who they want robin hood
wanted to get money back from
not the small business owners that were
selling bread and but robin had never
went and tried to take money away from
the people that are creating small
businesses
right that wasn't the idea robin hood
was trying to take money back from who
the big government that's bullying the
average guy that doesn't have any
control because of regulation right okay
people imposing taxes yeah so robinhood
started off as a great idea it was
purely accidental it went from what it
was i mean you did a great video on it
yourself just a couple days ago
it went we went from what it was hey
this is for average investors you're not
gonna have to pay anything just come
over here and get out you know do your
trades
beautiful story and it grew and it got
the attention of a lot of different
people
lots of big names lots of hollywood
people lots of celebrities you keep
seeing videos and advertisements from
these guys
that keep doing their thing but
eventually
when you raise 2.4 billion dollars
your boss is no longer the customer your
boss officially changed
when all of a sudden you go from your
customer
is middle america but your owners
is wall street you're conflicted oh yeah
big time big time so who are you loyal
to now
who do you have to listen to now who can
fire you now
who can say you know you got to get out
of here now you're sitting there saying
well these guys
this company is at 30 billion my net
worth is now xyz
what do i do how do i keep them happy
how do i keep the consumer happy but i
got to make sure these guys are happy
when they said when he shut down and
said no trading like you're talking
about vlad
yeah i mean you think people are naive
when elon musk is asking those questions
on uh
club um clubhouse clubhouse and he's
just grilling him 16 minutes
and going back and forth i mean you you
don't think people are naive that what
happened there
but it's not the point the board the
founder starts with a
vision and the vision is here's what
we're doing this company for the board
the buyer of the company when they come
in and they're like listen we love your
vision keep driving a company
but we like profits that's what we like
okay
so if you want to focus on profits this
so the relationship between those
two has to be set up in a way where the
vision and the cause doesn't change
if the vision and the cause changes you
could potentially lose your customers
that you already had although that's not
happening in robin hood
but today you're living in a different
time you're living in a time right now
where you're seeing a
parlor you're seeing a robin hood two
different stories parlor founders uh
maybe the guy that came out saying we
got to go against facebook we got to go
because
freedom of speech we have to have people
to be able to say whatever they want to
say because that was his message right
that's what we're gonna do but the money
guys are like listen that's great we
just gave you 10 million bucks
we just gave you 50 million bucks i'm
sorry give us our 50 million dollars
back i don't have that kind of money
now we're changing it so to changes we
have to bring somebody that's going to
be a little bit more
reasonable a little bit more there's
someone who probably gets along with big
tech a little bit better
you kind of have to do that right today
you kind of have to do you got to follow
the laws today
on the social side because so one day i
had a group of people in my office
and i wrote a map i said uh the
democrats are brilliant
dude they're so brilliant and i was
having this conversation last week i
think with uh
robert kiyosaki i think i know who it
was somebody was having this
conversation
last week yeah and i said republicans
chased money democrats chased
influence and control period let me say
that one more time yeah
republicans chase money which was what
man let me just make money and leave me
alone
okay so traditional business that you go
to
that you don't have influence but
traditional business day you're talking
about politically or actual
independent like voters i'm talking
politically okay
and power player billionaires that's
what i'm talking about
democrats said no we have to control
voice
so what did democrats billionaires start
buying l.a times
new york times washington post time
magazine
etc etc right then what do they do
amazon web services
now it's the biggest they're killing it
what they're doing amazon
facebook google you know
twitter go through all of them doors
all of these guys for republicans now to
compete
on the media side you know how long it's
going to take for them to compete in the
media site
decade two decades not one decade no way
two media side on the media side it's
gonna take
two decades for them to even have a shot
and by the way
two decades from now you think it'll be
50 50 even
no way two decades from now it will
still
only be 70 30. where do you think it is
now oh i think it's 98 to 2 right now
that that that big give me on the right
what the media has
one channel they've got fox you got
newsmax you've got newsmax is not
newsmax it's not
at the level you don't put those guys at
that level you have news as far as an
nbc you do not put them at that level
by the way if you look at right now it's
msnbc it's cnn it's fox then you got cbs
abc you know
all those other guys are all on on the
left they're not on the right so
so this is a little bit more of a
long-term
strategy that you know folks got to sit
down and kind of think about on what's
taking place you can't just sit there
and say
let me tell you this is not fair and
this is not this no it's not called not
fair it's called competition and it's
called you know
some of the strategies that you had
republicans on your side kind of didn't
help you out
and if you don't start making some
changes right now you're going to have
to
behoove and you're going to have to bow
down
to whatever they have to tell you
because they control
that's just what's going on period
so there there needs to be a major like
you know i'm on a flight back with a guy
uh jerry i'm trying to sleep because i
had three hours of sleep that day there
was a award ceremony i'm trying to
couple days ago a couple days ago but
jerry's got great stories
phenomenal stories and he's telling me
you know 1967 he started working for
bell and back in the days when
a you know a tnt had a uh what do you
call it a um
monopoly because atnt pretty much
controlled the market and the government
had to come in and break up at t
because you could only buy phone system
from one place so atnt would come in and
they would say hey
you know you got three plans which one
do you want i don't like any of these no
problem
okay cool good luck so can you imagine
there is nobody else that's coming to
your house afterwards so the government
said you can't do this so they broke
them apart
then they became different companies
anyways he finally said he said you know
what's the one thing about democrats
against republicans he said what
he says republicans compete against each
other democrats
unify even if they hate each other you
have to give them
credit they are united even if they hate
each other
there is more going on today with all
these businesses parlor robin hood
it's it's more political than people
even realize today this is no longer
about just doing business today
it's not it's a completely different
game so 27 28 year old that's going in
yeah and and you know the zucks of the
world who started facebook
zuck's brain is also a different kind of
a brain it's not a regular brain it's
you know in the in the gates brain and
the jobs young brain
those brains are wired in a different
way to compete
nowadays you you need to be ready you
need to have influence from many
different places
especially in the social media game so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye